okay
for people joining this live stream this
happens to be my
third live stream today gosh it's almost
uh living
life in public um this is
incremental language development uh a
variety of topics
for today we're starting off it seems
with
two tree related topics
okay should the order of arguments for
trees be data and then sub trees or
subtrees and then data
right so this is important because it
will determine everything else and
we are not sure and we have shown this
to for example chris and the first thing
he said is
why not data first
because
okay question what
the leaves of the tree are they trees
or are they naked expressions they are
also trees
you can input them as naked expressions
but they are also trees
okay but the question is then if we had
then what does it but but there's a
difference between a tree with no
successors and a naked expression right
tree open brace i mean
this form well
is different from that right
yes so the the first example would be
a non-terminal leaf like an ordinary
leaf would be either
data or tree of none common data
okay well i don't like us having if okay
why would you use tree of none common
data why would you not just use data
i think en is referring to a canonical
form in input it can be used
but it's good to canonicalize so that
we can perform operations consistently
is it i mean do we need to do that
do we need to canonicalize the leaves or
could they just be naked expressions
and say you wanted to have options
for the leaf yep
or you wanted to insert like do a tree
insert add a leaf
you know it is a tree
well i mean i don't think we want the
leaves of every tree to say
tree of none coma data that seems
extremely inelegant
on the other hand on the other hand we
don't want every single
random abstract tree to have a sub-tree
and then to have to say none for the
for the second argument
so we're we're we're toasted in both
cases
okay so okay so
let's review this again so
if we have an abstract tree
without any data which will be pretty
common
right that big abstract trees will be
common
am i making sense
so that argues okay so abstract trees
argues for tree of subtree
right okay yep
um you know data rich trees
argue for with so in tree of subtree
what would the leaves of an abstract
tree b
how abstract is the tree so there's like
an abstract tree in the sense that the
data is only stored in the leaves
or you can i mean no if we have a carey
tree
if we have this tree okay there's
nothing no data anywhere
exactly okay so what does that tree look
like
what are its leaves like
like tree of none common null
blah blah blah blah blah blah these
three has
indices right so each node has a number
that when we convert to the tree we need
to preserve
sure but you might want a tree like this
that doesn't have data
yeah yeah that i understand right but so
then this tree
in the case where we are forcing you
know
in the canonicalized form it will be
nice to be able to just have the leaves
be tree of no arguments
if you insist on having be being right
so so there's
three questions we have the order of the
arguments
and should subtrees be optional should
data be optional and also possibly
should both be optional
right well so the only reason you want
sub trees to be optional
is for the leaves right but potentially
the leaves
wouldn't have trees at all
see i would argue i don't think it makes
sense to have a tree wrapper around the
leaves
to to require a tree wrapper around the
leaves or even to canonicalize to that
i think it's wrong i don't think we want
it but
if if there are options if the leaf is
green we need to store it there right
fine just like we saw that in a graph
with annotations
if if you need to you can make it be
tree of um
now let's see this would be a sub tree
so it'd be none
comma data comma you know uh
you know style right
so therefore the the pure
tree the abstract graph like tree
i mean look with graphs
yeah the abstract graph like tree
would be a pure data structure that just
says tree of list of tree of blah blah
blah blah blah
and it would just look like that it
would just be a big nested collection of
tree objects
very much like uh you know
like tree expression
right tree expression and this would go
hand in hand
and because
well actually i yeah
i i still think subtrees goes first
who's arguing for it not going first
so to me the the parallel with with
expressions has always been important
and the fact that now the heads will be
placed last
why is it the head why is it ahead
because we visualize the data as i mean
if we have a tree expression
an expression tree sorry we will place
the heads as
payloads and and arguments as children
and for example that's what xml element
does and rules
xml almost is horrible though or
the input in rules three as en is
writing on the left so when we write
rules three we
say data arrow
list of children so three we'll
just go and flip that ah that's bad
is there anything else that does it in
the other order
text element yeah
what does text element do
it has the subtree first yeah and then
metadata
well actually you know at some level who
cares because nobody will see this
they'll just see things like this
yes eventually yeah
it's also important for us in the sense
of of ambiguities
with relation to what happens if the
data is
its rules they might get confused with
options
okay that's a good idea i'll strengthen
that to say that if the data is second
that it is actually
impossible to have the data be a valid
option to tree
so like kind of my preferred thing would
be to have data be optional like you
said
because of the the use case for abstract
trees
but to still have data be first
how would that work
how would you be able to distinguish i
see so in other words if what you see
is something like tree of list
tree tree comma
blah arrow blah
then then you know that there's a data
missing
tree with options
actually i mean that case will be rare
why would you want to style
an abstract tree with no data a red node
oh i see i see yeah
all right tree comma trees
i mean sorry sorry data comma subtrees
and that means the leaves of the tree
can be tree of data
no it's an independent question so i
think what ian is saying is that
with a single argument it's a list of
children
oh right right right right
right and the other one is is is this
that is a leaf which you don't have to
type normally
right right okay
okay i think i'm sold
okay and anything else to discuss here
again
hey this is a question reseating a tree
okay
i just think how that's gonna work
he said reseating well i mean if i want
to make a tree of trees that's gonna be
fine it's just gonna say tree of a list
of subtrees it's called good
yep yeah that's nice
that being able to do that without
having to introduce some kind of data
thingy
is nice an abstract tree of subtrees
that will be a that will be a common
thing to want to do i think
something else i was thinking about
before
after the meeting this morning is
is if if the user for example has a
collection of data
and all pieces of data have been wrapped
with the
with the head tree then
how to can we have three of
bracket other trees forming the tree so
that it's kind of
um well you're a verbatim tree is what
you're saying
that the leaf is a as a naked is a tree
expression
that doesn't represent a tree exactly
exactly so we have the nodes
separated because we have the pieces
like it's like forming
the tree by blocks so can we form them
just by application of all some pieces
into other pieces
um so three bracket
several trees bracket
tree bracket even a list of trees
so so lower case three of bracket
lowercase 3
log orchestra
oh a sub value right something like that
so
i mean it i'm also looking for
easy ways to construct trees
well that's interesting the sub values
of tree we haven't talked about
and whether we want accessors
i mean i think for graph theory our
whole vertex count
vertex list those are pretty nice i
prefer those
to having access all functions i mean to
having you know
sub values i think we were planning some
three children
and three data right um yeah
symbols yeah yeah so long as tree data
doesn't coin
you know have some problem with you know
ages of oak trees and things
never mind
um okay you know the sub values thing i
think is up for grabs
i don't know i think we should get the
thing built and then play with that
okay so my so my only
other two questions here were should the
sub trees also be optional
just tree open clothes
and what would that mean it'd be like
doing tree of none come a null so it's
this thing here yeah
it'd be a leaf with no data
probably i don't think it's that
important
yeah i don't know about that i asked me
again after you built it
okay you can put it in if you want to
but i'm just not sure
yep okay what's next
tree relative oh have you yeah you'll
need to update
documentation maybe look at the ref page
this is where we get the the uncle tree
and things yes
i'm very excited about this tree
functionality
it's going to be useful because it is it
sits very nicely between expressions
and graphs
right
okay documentation is updated
i think we'll be we'll have a hard time
understanding how we could have survived
so long without this
and i think we're going to end up
finding more
you know more uses for it in the entity
framework what was the thing i was
recently somebody was telling me
oh yeah the compiler abstract syntax
trees
okay tree relatives
okay represents a position or positions
or list of positions
relative to a sub-tree of a tree
um what does this even mean
see the examples uh no examples
okay so what do you what what's the
question here so this
is
you see i can imagine one day
being able to say um
[Music]
map f you know
hash comma tree relative
parent or something
is that obviously crazy
but forestry relative is part of the
part language so this is being used as a
pattern
i don't know what's being used so but
you're saying that if i extract
oh by the way the sub sub element thing
we should use the sub element thing as
an extractor
for trees
right like if i say tree one one
two one two right that should be the sub
tree
that corresponds to that that's where we
should use the sub values
seems reasonable
and then we should probably have the
alighted syntax
um
[Music]
you know
how can you have nephews without nieces
they should be equivalent fine
okay but i mean
okay so then we'd say tree two
three one nephews is that right
yep
well tree relative of nephews well
that's what i'm
not saying okay hold on
okay why is it useful to have tree
relative there
oh because that could be a named branch
is that true
yeah you might have collisions with keys
if you're using associations
all right fine
the alternative would be to force key on
on the keys
so one of them must be no i don't think
we should do that i don't think we
should do that
i think it'd be better to have the true
relative thing
and in in in terms of the tree extractor
language
we could say two comma four here and
that would give us a list out correct
yeah yeah in fact nephews represents a
list
i understand that's why i'm bringing
that up right but now i have the
question if i do this
what what shape of object do i get do i
get a two by three array
yes okay
and what happens if one of those
things doesn't have all of these cases
it will be an error i can extract right
now it's not a missing
we're planning on returning a missing
right
hopefully with more information like if
you try to extract
a missing key from an association it
returns a missing
fine i think that's the right thing to
do
okay
ethan on our live stream says it'd be
nice to support hyper trees too what the
heck is a hyper tree
i should know that shouldn't i let's see
a hyper tree would must be
i don't understand what it is because a
a tree
you know it's like a graph has relations
between two things
and a hyper graph has relations between
more than two things but a hyper tree
would be i see each branch here
but it's just a partitioning of branches
isn't it
i don't think it's different i think
this is different as with hyper golfs
i may be confused but don't think it is
i have never heard of the concept fair
enough
um yeah but we need to explore it it
does have a
documentation okay
there's a question from purkinje about
if a tree can be predicted in some way
so that's a question of of feeding this
into the machine learning system do we
have do we have that discussed yet
how to make an encoder for trees
we were discussing the other day about
decision trees and how
to train right that's good
yeah um
so we learned about the needs of that
project and
i see but i mean a different issue which
we should address is
if you feed a tree in
to you know predict for example let's
say you're trying to predict tree let's
say
you've got abstract syntax trees and
you're trying to classify them
do we know how to do that that's the
question it's a question to be
brought to the machine learning team
okay um
let's see kobe says it would return
all nephews but need to distinguish
which order nephew parent etc
oh yeah so the issue is okay so there is
a question of what order
the okay so let's say
okay the children of a node so in other
words
this if i said tree tree relative
children tree relative children
that's effectively taking the tree
and making it into some kind of depth
first array
is that correct
i right now i don't i don't know which
one it is but i think
what we do already in part sets a
precedent that we need
we need to follow okay
it's the same situation you had before
these pair of lists
yeah right but i mean i think that the
my point is
one of the things that this is
highlighting and i guess we don't have
this
is an array tree
right in other words if i've given if i
give you an array
right there is an implicit tree
associated with that array
it's like a quad tree or something if i
was doing image processing
i couldn't i could give you a um
i mean even something well now this
expression tree would presumably make it
right but does that work i have to be in
do i have to be in the prototype build
yeah
i think the set of functions naturally
dedicated to
arrays and the set of functions
naturally dedicated to trees are
separate
so in arrays we have dimensions
transpose yeah right and i mean in this
case it can be ragged right it can have
a
nesting down exactly okay so what about
data set
data set has some kind of tree-like
structure too
it'd be nice to be able to convert
between data set and tree
in fact a tree a dataset might be a nice
way to view a tree
quite a nice way to view a tree actually
okay so now you say i can say here
um
what
that's weird
well whatever something went wrong okay
okay
anyway so more stuff to say here is
there anything more to say i mean
is there an issue here or is there not
an issue here this is basically you're
saying that part already defines its
hierarchical way
of of uh you know
having a list of these parts with a sub
list of these parts
right i think we first create the list
corresponding to the first level and
then we go
inside each of them and create a sublist
for each of the
children of those and continue
right okay right all right anything else
some trees
yeah so there were some excluded notes
on tree relative
[Laughter]
oh gosh
surely there's got to be a um
uh
one of the notes down there
which oh nibblings okay
we should support nibblings we should
support nephews nieces and nibblings
right i think if we recommend all of
them together it becomes
gender neutral yes just just
document them on a line nephew's
commonly nibblings
right blings what is a pibbling
what is a pibbling the situation's worse
for aunts and uncles because
it there's not a word that's accepted
nearly to the extent that nibbling
is
that's because they're an older
generation they didn't get as funky with
these things
yeah the oh gosh
well just wait um
look i think siblings children parents
siblings
i think aunts and uncles is pretty weird
frankly
and i'd be perfectly happy to call it
particularly this is tree relative right
so
i could imagine a
you know something where you say
in the tree relative specification is it
equivalent to just say
tree relative
parent parent
siblings is that possible
that works but siblings children
will not be equivalent because of the
fact that they represent a list
like the combined thing would just go
get
the uh what is it well the list of
children but
why wouldn't this be getting i don't
understand this tree relative thing
why couldn't you because look if i would
like to say
okay so we also need the pure
you know uh common ancestor
you know distance to common ancestor and
then removal whatever it is
cousins right but so common ancestors so
if i say
tree relative um
minus one that gets the parent true
relative 1 gets the children
presumably
and then tree relative
okay so now how do i go up to
grandparents
and down to cousins so there i would go
up to grandparents
and down to cousin right
that's the cousin
that's one of the one of the kinds of
parameterizations we want
is to be able to do something like that
i think it's important to be able to do
this i think it's more important than
them pebblings and things oh but sander
observes
siblings must come from parental
siblings well that's good that's a good
that's a good observation yeah
go ahead what were you going to say i i
just said that's why
i had that as the first note well
three types of parent parameterizations
we made oh i wasn't reading this i was
inventing it for myself sorry
number of levels okay whether to include
the current branch
okay so how would you like siblings and
siblings not self we have but we don't
have like
nephews and also nephews
not chill not counting the children or
including the children
okay so this is okay so here
tree relative minus two two can i just
understand what that is that's cousins
right
first cousins but including yourself
no there's a standard if cousins
includes
your children or not
i see so if i went if i went minus two
three
doesn't include my children
right because i went up to grandparents
then i came down the other branches of
the tree and did i go through myself or
not
right so do you go back down your same
branch
as well or not
it's a good way to put it
for some of these we have an alternate
form
that excludes the branch right but for
like nephews we just exclude the branch
by the way ethan is pointing out the
function repository has a bunch of
interesting
tree stuff have we looked been looking
at this
not a function repository i'll take a
look need to
it's a nice one that tree map thing is a
nice one
i don't know about this by the way
dendrograms have to map properly into
trees
right and and the dendrogram way of
visualizing
a tree dendrogram of a tree should
presumably visualize a tree
well what should that do
i think there's a question here because
dendrograms i think
the height of the brand of the branches
matters
that would have to be part of the data
yeah i think
okay well so then it's a standardized
piece of the data just like
in the case of um uh for graphs we can
have certain standardized attributes
this is useful to be able to go back and
forth between dendrograms and trees
okay i want to come back to true
relative stuff okay
so if i'm understanding correctly we
went through this last time
in genealogy there is a standard there
are two there are standard parameters
how far you go up and how far you come
down
right do we agree you go back to a
common ancestor you go forwards to
comments
to successors correct
okay so now the only issue is do you
um well so there's a wrinkle that the
second number is usually the difference
in level between you and the relative i
know for the removal thing
but i think probably for tree relative
that we should not do it that way
we should do it relative to the to where
you got to okay
because i have this feeling that i might
be wrong about
that this also makes sense
does it make sense or is that
meaningless
i think if you exclude self that's going
to be different
but in these things for example -2 3 do
does that represent a list or a matrix
i think it's a list
i think i think if you want a matrix use
multiple tree relatives
right if you want a matrix use list
sorry use tree of tree relative
minus two tree relative three
i see that will give you a matrix
okay okay i want to understand this i'm
pretty sure that this makes sense
and i think it is okay so the question
is and also how do we
exclude self right
i don't think we should should we
exclude self by default
could be a second argument of true
relative specifically
that's a good idea
yeah okay um
something which gives an information
about whether to use self whether to
include self
or or it might be a string specifying
various things you might want to do
at the moment we just what are those
things i mean
okay my feeling is with these strings
let's let's uh throttle back on the
aunts and uncles
okay let's not do them we'll do children
grandparents
grandchildren siblings but not a lot
else
okay because i think it's it's
i mean maybe we could do nibblings just
for fun
but um
i mean part of the reason is you're
gonna get very confused because human
genealogy
doesn't work like this right the uncle
you don't usually talk about the uncle
you know you talk about the sibling
nodes you really do not talk about the
uncle nodes
and and you know it's just really
confusing
um
seems good to me i mean we start without
them and see whether right but
can we confirm whether this is right
whether i'm right that there's a
different thing you get from this
so so that's a bunch of notes from your
same generation
because they all add up to zero
so that's what that's what you're saying
is that supposed to be you go
up to grandparent then you go down to
the great grandchildren of
your grandparent and then you look at
each of their grandparents
and then you look at each of those
people's children
and you get you have me confused okay
hold on you go up to the grandparents
you go down to their great-grandchildren
okay that's what this is doing right at
that point you've
spread out on the tree you're now you're
now visiting
all their great grandchildren by the way
by the way by the way by the way
there's there's a case of intermediate
nodes
only only the only the boundary only the
rim
versus the whole
path do you understand what i'm saying
so if i say
back to grandparents there's the
question of do i include my parents
in going back to the grandparents or do
i only include the boundary of the
region
that is the grandparents
i see right
so minus two could
be i mean in a sense that's the minus
two this is related to ancestors
for example like yes ancestors
grandparent but you don't have great
grandparent
and great great grandparent
it makes sense to treat it a bit like a
level spec
where an extra level of
race indexing means only that level
that's interesting idea i think you're
going to want only that level most of
the time though
i agree with that so we probably don't
want to quite do it that way but but
um um
right so so you understand there's the
rim and the path
um yes i'm pretty sure that as you go
forward backward forward backward okay
so so here's an interesting question
if i say tree relative 1 1
is it the same as true relative two
okay so that's my children's children
[Music]
no i think it's by default it isn't the
same because of its rim
by default this is my children and my
grandchildren
and this is just my grandchildren you
see what i'm saying
i think maybe i don't know question mark
see what i'm saying so it's a question
of whether for each of those
do i or is this
just grandchildren
all right i think you need to get some
of these implemented what's that
i think you might actually want to
almost do the reverse of our level specs
where
if you want every generation along the
way
you put everything in an extra level
abrasion yeah i think that might be
right
and and you can specify and the
justification for that would be
you specify the spray of generations
that you want
yeah so if i say tree relative and i
want
generations two through four
that's what i would do
no but then the defaults would be if i
say
tree relative you know just four
that that will be equivalent to
tree relative of one comma four is it
one comma four or zero comma four
four is by default equivalent to one
four
well these are not level specs
but they feel very much like levels so
they're not
quite the same but
yes they are similar it's like the
non-negative ones are similar but the
negative ones are
different well and they are relative
so our level aspects are always
absolute
um okay
anyway look so there's some interesting
things to figure out here um
i also would like to point out another
thing which is i could imagine that in
tree relative
yeah here's another point ag
oh i see no no so you say i'd go back to
grandchildren
um grant yeah grandparents
so i say tree i've got my tree here tree
relative that
go back to grandparents then go forward
to minus two thank you
and then i go forward on the a branch so
tree relative
is a now now okay so here let me let me
make it even more difficult
for you what about this can we do that
can we do pattern matching for branches
that would be cool
i think it's gonna discuss using
patterns
in position specs i think for like
tree replace part okay yeah well so fine
but then in that case we could
i'm not it's not clear to me how
like how broad we want to go with that i
think it'd be nice eventually to go
broader but doesn't need to be done on
day one
okay but this is a way of so that would
get me so
the reason that's useful is because
accept might be useful
as a way of avoiding self somehow
i don't completely understand how yet
oh let's go back to my
um the two arguments of accept we could
say
children accept
i don't remember the two argument forms
except i feel bad
represents any pattern that matches p
but not c o brilliant
okay so we'd say except
minus two comma zero or something
well no actually that isn't right it'd
be minus two
it would be minus two comma two
except zero ie
ie cousins excluding self
but the theorem is then a position
i guess what what is no it's a level
oh shoot no i no no it's a tree relative
designation right so tree relative
designation of zero
is self
i see
perhaps we should support the string
itself there
it's more readable yeah probably i mean
yes fair enough fair enough
okay so uh
meat on our live stream is is um um
saying that in swedish you can select
the grandchildren from which son
or daughter
in other words the cousin
when you say my cousin i guess
you're saying the child of my uncle
the child of uncle so and so
which but if you want to do that you
should just use
actual tree
okay here's a question
no right right right yeah right you just
go tree relative
and then you go forwards right you'd say
tree
of tree relative minus
two and then you would say the actual
person is bob and then
their children
right that would get you their children
right okay
all right anything else with this right
now i don't think so
great wonderful all right let's quickly
look at palindrome and a couple of other
things here
um
yes we should have this no reason not to
yes i agree why not
tough luck
that's okay
oh gosh this is an issue that's an issue
so i think our general idea here is to
have a dedicated second argument that
specifies what you want and so we make
this function
like have supported multiple cases
yes but that case of len is really
important
for numbers because the very common
thing is is digit reversal
of a certain length right
and and now that we support b it feels
very natural to add that too
a third argument well we were planning
to have
everything packed in the second in this
case that's a good idea
because i think it's like integer digits
right has
you know interdigits is separate
arguments i really think it has to be
separate arguments
it's a little weird right because then
it becomes less clear
this type
well no i think it's clear it's a type
by the fact that it's got a
you know i guess
we would have to say additional
arguments specify the type
because we may have types also for
string
cases what types for string cases
there may be palindromes that do
different things like considering
separate words ignore
planks i don't know i don't know much
about this but there are multiple
several cases of some examples um
if you go to the page for palindrome
queue
the source page
source page okay
that's a lot of green
by the way ethan is making various
comments about tree node and binary tree
and so on
the name that we're using is just tree
it's not tree node it's not tree
elements it's just
tree because trees are self eating
a tree eats trees now that requires by
the way
some consistency fix up in the data
structure project
so can you guys take responsibility for
that
well i think that currently the binary
tree data structure
has some names that are not consistent
i see yeah and there's also like avl
tree kd there's just a bunch of trees
well just make sure that they're
consistent yeah but the the
meaning of different things is the same
and you also should probably check i
mean by the way
in terms of the tree scanning orders and
things do we have a
have you yet designed that how we have
functions that scan the tree
that'll be remap okay
but then is there a traversal order yes
there's a traversal order option to tree
map
how is it parametrized you can say
post order pre-order or level order
okay i mean that's going to come into
map one day
map and scan are going to want that
by the way is there a tree scan
no we should think about it
um
let's see and and also tree interacting
with the compiler i'm sure you're going
to take care of that
yeah writing it using the compiler
yeah for if you have a tree a a piece of
code that involves tree
that that will work with the compiler
right there will be an easy way to
extract the data structure directly and
continue with that
right that's the idea
oh boy what is this
i think ian is referring to the next to
last
with types of
oh boy i'm sure ed pegg is an expert on
these
it's the type of thing he would know
about um
look for goodness sake it's not exactly
that hard to program
an arbitrarily complicated palindrome
maybe we should skip this stuff maybe
this is getting too complicated
so it's not that we are proposing to
implement all of this it's just the idea
of if we want the numeric case with b
and len
how do we do it so that we don't spoil
future
right exceptions okay so the cases that
i think will matter well
you know paradromes and biosequences are
important
look if there's going to be a palindrome
with
bases it's palindrome without bases is
just kind of
cutesy because it's just base 10 and i
don't know why anybody would care other
than for number problems
you know for a number of puzzles the
case you know there are algorithms where
you need
i mean it's pretty obscure it's pretty
obscure
i say we leave this for the time being
let's not break anything let's make sure
that we can get by
palindrome and biosequence to work
palindrome queue of biosequence to work
make sense um
but but we do support b right in the
second
i'm i'm thinking not no okay
i mean look it's it's it's very bizarre
what you mean by that
unless you know the length of the number
with the leading zeros i don't know what
you mean
i think it's pretty useless without
leaving zeros
i mean it's just amusement without the
leading zeroes
i mean it may be worth it i don't know i
mean ask ed pegg
okay whether he thinks it's you know
whether he cares without leaving zeroes
um
well i mean we can have three arguments
for the particular case of numbers
and then for the other cases the second
argument will be a type
it's just some sort of exceptional case
for numbers
ah i don't know i think we're being too
complicated here i mean
how difficult is it to say blah blah
blah equals reverse of blah blah blah
yeah true
oh boy sandra is pointing out that 100
would be a palindrome if we
oh what a mess no 100 will be a
palindrome
if it was a five digit number so zero
zero one zero zero would be a palindrome
now cobb over here is is commenting on
if you have a tree of n nodes
then wouldn't any arbitrary node have n
possible components associated with it
where components of various higher and
lower order family and archaeology
titles family archaeology titles so that
is a good question
how many
how many overlapping
subtrees right so it's the number of
yeah i think it's it's simply
parameterized by that question of how
far do you go back in common ancestry
how far do you go forward i believe but
again this back and forth thing i do not
understand
and it may be that it always collapses
unless you're excluding selfs
that make sense and you see i don't
think it'll collapse if you exclude
forwards forward light cones effectively
forward tree
cones if you understand what i'm saying
in other words
if you and your children are excluded
from your nibblings
then that's going to propagate forwards
if that makes sense yep
um
okay all right
let's see anything else we need to look
at
here uh there's a okay utility functions
under discussion
okay yeah that's a different discussion
i think i don't think yeah
i think we should postpone this to
another meeting
all right anyway trees look wonderful so
let's get them finished um
okay and i think that wraps it up
for now and um to be continuing another
time
all right thanks guys thanks for